Zack Bodner, thank you so much for
joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
It’s my pleasure.
Thank you for inviting me, Michael.
You know, when I look at you,
I think of the person
that’s allowing me
to get Israeli entertainment
in Palo Alto because
before corona times,
I would come almost weekly
to the JCC for the
weekly Israeli artists.
I know that I may be
experiencing the JCC different
than a lot of other people
around the community,
but that’s --
you gave me such a great gift.
So, first of all, thank you.
It’s really great.
It’s my pleasure.
And I’m glad that
you’re taking advantage
of all of the opportunities
we’re offering, or at least one
of the many opportunities
we’re offering.
And in this time of lockdown,
we’re doing a virtual --
all of JCC. And the Israeli stuff
that’s happening on Facebook Live
is phenomenal.
So, I hope you’re taking advantage
of that as well.
- A hundred percent.
- There’s a lot of other stuff you
could be doing as well, Michael.
And when we open up,
hopefully, sometime soon,
I’m happy to share with you
what those are as well.
I would love that, Zack,
you’ve been involved
on the intersection of
Israel-America Judaism for so long.
But actually, you started off
by playing varsity soccer in Yale.
Is that correct?
[laughs]
Yes. I don’t know
if that’s where I started,
but I definitely started
at a certain point there.
Yes, I did. I went to Yale
to get the great education
that Yale offers
and to play soccer.
I was recruited
to play soccer there.
I played goalie
and it was an
incredible experience.
I actually took
a little bit of a break.
I went and studied
at Hebrew University in Jerusalem
for one semester,
my junior year
at the Rockford School.
And while I was there,
I actually played with
[Hapoel Jerusalem]
so I played a little bit of ball
- with them and throughout --
- No way, you played --
professionally
with [Hapoel Jerusalem]?
Not officially because
I was playing NCAA ball.
NCAA is the National Collegiate
Athletic Association.
So when you're playing with them --
Actually, my girlfriend
at Stanford just won
the national championship
this year
- as a striker.
- Hey, mazel tov!
Mazel tov [unclear].
Great.
[laughs]
So, I trained with them.
I trained with Hapoel, I didn't
play officially with them.
But it was a great experience.
That’s what changed my life
that time in Israel,
I met the woman
who I ended up marrying,
- Wow!
- Ronit
-- became my wife and made
the best friends of my life.
I came back and I realized
this is what I wanted to do
with my life, something related
to Israel and the Jewish people.
- So, here I am.
- What did you study at Yale?
I studied psychology and I focused
on psychology of religion.
I’ve always been a seeker.
I’ve always been kind of a Jew
in the wilderness, right?
Looking for the answers.
And so, this was kind of like,
"Why do people ask these
big life questions?"
And I thought,
"Why does the dog
howl at the moon?"
These are the sort of questions
that I was always asking
that led me ultimately
to graduate school.
work in philosophy of religion
and theology, which is highly
marketable, let me tell you.
What you’re doing with GSB
is going to get you
a much better job
out of graduate school
than what I did
with a graduate degree
in theology, Michael.
Amazing! I definitely --
GSB’s definitely
in my radar right now.
I’m still in the undergrad,
but I love that --
I love -- people
think that I’m in the GSB.
So, right now, it’s planting seeds
in my mind that I know
I can get there,
and I’ll get there one day.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- Wonderful.
I think it’s your maturity
having spent time in the army.
You’re older than most
of the young students
at Stanford, I think.
I hope to get there one day.
And I just love it.
I am trying to take a bunch
of GSB courses because it’s --
just the building next door.
But that’s for another topic. Zack,
I want to talk for a second
about Judaism 4.0.
You had a great TEDx talk
that you gave about it
and I love the very first sentence
that you said.
You said Judaism
is a lot of things,
but at the same time,
it’s none of those things.
So, please give me a little bit
of insight into
what is this Judaism 4.0.
Yeah, right. Well, Judaism is --
it’s a religion.
It’s not a religion.
It’s a people.
It’s not a people.
It’s an ethnicity.
It’s not an ethnicity.
It’s a moral code.
It’s a culture, right?
It’s all of the above
and none of the above.
It’s 3,000 years old,
and yet, people are still confused
by what Judaism is.
- Definitely.
- And that’s because it's evolved
over time. And I talk about
4.0, Michael, because
I believe we’re in
the fourth era of Judaism.
The first era was the era
of the Mishkan.
We were wandering in the desert
and our portable holiness
went with us. 2.0, we settled
in Israel, the Holy Land.
We built the temple.
It was destroyed.
Built the next temple.
But that period of centrality,
our spirituality had a home.
And then, destroyed in 70 CE.
You know the story.
And ever since then,
we’ve been in the 3.0 era,
which is the dispersion --
- Right.
- the exile, right?
But what’s happening,
and ever since
the kind of the enlightenment,
is Judaism has started
to realize that it can also be
a part of secular
society, too, right?
And this is what's
confused people about --
is it religion
or is it not a religion?
How can you convert out, and yet,
how can the Nazis still say,
“Well, you’re Jewish,”
even if you converted?
Does it mean there’s a blood issue,
there’s ethnicity?
Well, now, we know Jews
can also be Asian.
They can be African-American.
- Right.
- They can be Latino, right?
It’s not just about Yiddish.
It’s not ashkenormative. Right?
As we think about.
- I have heard that one before.
- There's Sephardi Jews. I married
a nice Sephardi girl.
I like that.
[laughs]
Yeah.
So, we’re now
in this moment of 4.0.
We’re on the cusp.
And it’s a lot of different factors
that are contributing
to this moment,
but it’s creating
a sociological crash.
Right? Our whole outlook
has been flipped on its head.
So, we have to ask ourselves,
what is the Judaism
of the future going to look like?
So, our job, our vision at the JCC
here in Palo Alto
is to be the architects
of the Jewish future.
We consider ourselves
to be the ones helping people
think about how can they do
Jewish their way.
So, Michael, you came
and you connected
to your Israeli-ness --
- Right.
- here at the JCC, right?
And so, one of the things
we’re saying is,
how do the Israelis bring
their version of Judaism here
to American-Jews
and how can we
as American-Jews
export that to Israel?
That’s one of things
we need to think about, right?
Because a lot of Israelis,
as you probably know,
think that you’re either secular
or you’re orthodox.
And they’ll recognize
us a lot in between.
Right? And American Judaism
has this whole Mosaic
in between our idea of
[Khilonim]
- Yeah.
- Right?
But if Israelis can see that here
and bring that back --
So, I’ll give you an example.
- Right?
- Please.
Some Israelis,
shlichim
who come here experience
American Judaism,
they saw what a reformed
Jewish synagogue,
a Friday night service
could be like.
And they went back,
and they brought that
to the Namal in Tel-Aviv,
on the port.
And now you go on a Friday night --
Yeah.
-- with beautiful service, right?
Mixed men and women, and singing.
- And Israeli would be like,
- Yeah.
- "Mazel! What is this?" Right?
- [laughs]
That’s an Israeli import
from American Judaism.
- Right.
-By the same token,
I think we, in America,
we need to import
the idea of the Mechina program.
- Yeah.
- The idea of Jewish service
that all Israelis like you
serve in the army.
How can we do this
for American-Jews,
so they feel like
they’re a part of something
in the community and not just,
“I’ve had my bar mitzvah.
[unclear] I’m done.”
Right now, I think one
of the things I was exposed at
is through J-Ventures,
which you’re also an LP of,
and the fun that
we’re both involved with.
But I came to the room
and you had about
a hundred partners in the room,
all incredible executives
and investors.
A lot of them, Israelis;
a lot of them, American-Jewish.
And all of a sudden,
I believe there were some
Americans there who said that
this is their first
interaction with Israelis.
Israelis, all of a sudden, are
communicating with American-Jews
and not just, you know,
in the Sunnyvale kibbutz
So, I think that I’m learning
also that there are
these huge differences.
And one of the things
that I was exposed
to was the idea that, as an Israeli,
I don’t remember
the last time my friends and
I really visited
a synagogue in Israel.
Yet, a lot of my
Jewish friends here,
it’s kind of a thing
to go to synagogue.
And it almost feels like
you’re more Jewish than I am,
and I’m very Jewish.
So, it’s very interesting to see
all these different cultures
come together.
Right. I think that
with your experiencing
and being a part of --
with J-Ventures and at the JCC
is this acknowledgement
that we can learn from each other
and be a part
of each other’s worlds,
and give and take spiritually,
culturally, religiously.
And then, we can love each other
as a family even if we disagree.
- Yeah.
- And this is the part that
I fear actually, Michael,
is that this next generation
of young American-Jews
are only judging
their relationship with Israel
through the two things
that they have issues with. Right?
the Israel’s treatment
of the Palestinians and also
the Chief Rabbinate of Israel.
The two things that many
American-Jews disagree with,
that’s the whole lens
though which they view Israel
is through those two things.
And I’m saying no, no, no.
The relationship with Israel
is much bigger,
much more beautiful,
much longer lasting
and much more complicated.
And you have to kind of transcend
those differences.
And by the same token,
I’m saying to Israeli-Jews,
don’t just look at us
as failed Zionists
because we don’t have
the ḥutspâ [unclear]
Don’t just look at us and say,
“You’re not even
going to be Jewish
in a few generations
because of intermarriage
or simulation, or anti-Semitism.
So, we’re talking past each other.
And what you’re seeing
with organization like J-Ventures
or the work we’re doing
here at the JCC
is this integration,
the weaving together
of Israeli-Jews and American-Jews,
and it’s making all of us better.
And that way, if something happens
like in the next few weeks
with annexation,
Michael, there’s going to be --
especially, in the liberal
bay area, there’s
going to be a lot of
[unclear]
for American-Jews
around what’s happening in Israel.
But if you love Israel
and you recognize
that they have to make
some tough decisions
that maybe we don’t agree with --
and we have every right
to talk about
our positions in these
but don’t let it define your
entire relationship with Israel.
Right? Figure out how
just like when you’re sitting
around the Shabbat table, Michael,
with your crazy Uncle Larry
who has crazy views --
maybe he’s a Trump-lover
and you’re not.
Or maybe he hates Trump
and you love Trump,
but you’re still family.
And you have to figure out
how to sit around
the Shabbat’s table
and the Pesach table
and embrace each other
even if you’re arguing.
This is what Jews have done
for generations,
- the machloket.
- Yeah.
We’ve never agreed on each other.
Yeah. You put two Jews in a room,
you get three different opinions.
- Right?
- Exactly. Exactly.
Zack, talk to me a little bit
about where are we headed.
You’re seeing these trends.
You were a part of AIPAC
for many, many years.
In leadership positions,
both at  the JCC and AIPAC,
where are we headed,
let’s say, 10 years from now
or 20 years from now?
Are there big changes?
Are there different trends?
Optimism? Pessimism?
Yeah, I think that there are trends
that can go either way, frankly.
Number 1, we’re seeing
institutional affiliations
dropping. Right?
So, membership in American
synagogues is dropping,
the old legacy institutions
are dropping.
And you have the older
generation of Jews
who are wringing their hands and
[unclear]
and worried but they shouldn’t be
because this next generation,
your generation, you’re not
walking away from Judaism.
They’re starting up new,
cool Jewish ways of doing, right?
There’s the Urban Adamah,
and there's Moishe House,
and there’s Wilderness Torah,
and there’s At The Well.
But there’s also
this ethos of the Jewish
- Tikkun Olam social action, right?
- Okay.
Jews are doing Jewish
by getting involved
with the racial
justice movement.
Right? So, they’re still
doing Jewish.
Right.
But the dropping
of institutional affiliation
is going to change the landscape.
That’s the trend
that we have to watch out for.
The second trend
is the ethno-graphics
are shifting, Michael,
which means that
it’s no longer about,
are you Ashkenazi
or you're Sephardi?
like I said, right?
There are Jews of color.
I’ll tell you a story.
There’s a Japanese woman
on our board of directors here
at the JCC. She’s not Jewish.
She didn’t convert.
She married a Jewish guy.
The Jewish guy,
he doesn’t really care
about doing Jewish.
He’s happy that his wife cares.
She’s the one who’s doing --
She’s Japanese
and she’s the one driving
the kids to Hebrew schools.
She’s the one
who makes challah.
who does the Passover.
So, tell me, who’s Jewish
in that relationship?
- Right?
- Right.
The future is going to be long
to those people
who choose to do Jew --
We’re all going to be
Jews by choice.
Right? We’re all going to be
That’s another trend
we have to pay attention to.
The third is,
this is the first time
ever, ever, ever in Jewish history
where there’s both
a strong Jewish
homeland in Israel
and a strong Jewish diaspora,
mainly here in America.
It’s been one or the other,
but now we have both
and figuring how we work together.
It goes back to
what I was saying before.
We have to find a way
to transcend our differences.
These trends are going to
be incredibly important.
- The last thing I'll say is --
doesn’t it feel also
that the Jews in diaspora,
or the centralized,
ones in the US,
it still feels pretty fragmented.
Now, you have a strong
centralization of Jews in,
let’s say, New York.
And then, you have in Palo Alto.
And you have maybe north --
so, do you consider
that centralized
or is that also --
because the distance from
here to New York
is just as great as, you know,
from Israel to London.
It’s true. But those distances
are breaking down now
because of the ability to do
exactly what you and I
are doing right now.
And that speaks to
what I think is
the last biggest trend,
science and technology.
The massive pace
and speed of science and technology
are changing everything.
Look, you and I
can have this conversation
even though we’re just
a couple of miles away
from each other.
Or we could do this
with folks in Israel.
You can have a
Charedi woman and a secular man,
or vice versa actually talking
like this now
right across time zones,
across mechitza.
You can have age. No, it goes
away all of a sudden.
So, yes, there is a central
place here in Palo Alto,
and a central place in New York
but we’re breaking down
these barriers now.
And so, think about
how we can now
have real Talmud study
with the chavruta
that’s sitting thousands
and thousands of miles away.
Okay, think about
how science and technology
are changing things.
So, it’s not just
the Shabbat’s elevator
in Jerusalem, Michael,
but what if Tesla allows
for a Shabbat’s car.
So, now we can drive on Shabbats.
Imagine if -- they’re now figuring
out how to make these
impossible burgers
and these plant-based meat.
So, imagine now that we
can have actually kosher pork
and kosher bacon.
Science is changing everything
and those are the small things.
But imagine the big things as well.
Imagine when virtual reality
allows us to actually
stand at the base
of Mt. Sinai and experience
revelation for ourselves. Right?
So, time goes away.
Space goes away.
Science and technology
is changing everything
and those are the positive
trends, but it can also
have a dark side as well.
For example, the genetic testing.
If somebody says,
“Well, you can now test
whether you are
genetically Jewish or not,
and that means you’re
either in or you’re out,
I could see that going in a very,
very dark and scary [unclear].
No. And obviously,
I mean in Israel,
there’s a bunch
of different conflicts.
in Tel-Aviv just recently,
they very recently announced
that gay couples
can declare themselves married
and get the benefits
of being married,
which is a huge,
huge incredible feat
that they managed
to get through, finally.
But I’m also witnessing in Israel
that there is a greater conflict
emerging between secular Jews
and religion Jews within Israel,
between the regular citizens,
and then the Karaites.
And one of the amazing things
that I’ve been observing
through technology
and such is Moshe Friedman
from Bnei Brak.
[unclear] already.
He brings on this amazing group
of Karaite technology enthusiasts
and creates this
venture capital arm in
Bnei Brak, bringing together
also people from Tel-Aviv
and creating this mishmash,
and showing that,
yes, we’re actually
not that different.
Sure, one eats pork.
The other one doesn’t.
But we’re all the same
people at the end.
And I think it’s beautiful.
Zack, we have
just a few minutes left.
I want to get your mind
about leadership a little bit
because you have dozens of years
of experience with leadership.
And I’d love to get your point
on leadership as a whole.
Thank you, Michael.
And it’s been a great conversation.
I love the way
that you’ve made this happen.
It’s very grassroots
and it’s very indicative
of what’s going to happen
in this next generation.
- Right? No longer
- Thank you.
do you have to have somebody
heckschering you,
blessing you, saying,
“You are now a leader; therefore,
you get to interview whomever."
It’s going to come up
and bubble up organically,
grassroots the way you have.
- So, I love that you’re
- Thank you.
an example of this.
And thank you for inviting me
to be a part of this conversation.
Look, leadership takes
all forms as we know.
And people talk about
peace time leaders
and war time leaders,
peace time CEOs,
war time CEOs.
And you have to take on
different personality types
for different environments.
I think about what
a real leader has to do
and what a real leader
doesn’t have to do.
And I have this acronym.
It just happens to be
the word scaffolding.
I think a real strong leader
has to offer the scaffolding
and allow the rest of his
or her team to do the rest.
And what does
this scaffolding entail?
The S, you have
to offer the strategy.
How can you be
the one thinking about
what it’s going to take
to achieve the goals
of the organization?
The C, you have to change
the culture and set the culture.
And determine, are you going to
micromanage or you can give people
a lot of freedom.
Is it going to be a culture
of shared leadership or not, okay?
I think the A is the architecture.
What does this setup
of the organization look like?
What does the org chart look like?
Who reports to whom? Right?
F, focus. You have to provide
the focus so that people
are not wandering off.
But you also have to allow people
a little bit of autonomy in that.
- Right.
- The second F is forecasting.
You have to be
able to see the future.
Right? People are looking for
what is the future.
What's right around the bend?
Some of the questions you asked me.
Right? The O is for oversight
and determining what oversight.
Are you going to measure
daily metrics, weekly KPIs,
monthly, quarterly?
What does that look like?
Right? The L is for leadership,
okay? Leadership development.
And that’s not just kind of
like the generic way,
but who are you
looking to in the future
to bring onto your
board of directors
to be your next round of investors?
Right? Who’s your kitchen cabinet?
That’s leadership development.
So, not just a one-man show,
but who are the people
that are going to help you
and help the whole
organization lead with you.
Right, exactly.
I is inspiration.
In many ways, the CEO
has to be the CIO,
the Chief Inspiration Officer.
Right? The N is for networkt
because you are the guy at the top
or the woman at the top
and you are the only one
who could talk to other leaders
at that level.
So, you are the one who keeps
that network in your own industry.
Right? So, the network is the N.
And finally, the last is the G,
which is the golden circle.
Simon Sinek has
this great TED talk.
You’ve probably seen it
about the golden circle.
Yes
We all have to sell for the center
of the circle, which is the why.
So, you as the leader,
have to provide the why.
What is the reason why you are
doing whatever you’re doing?
So, that’s how I think
about leadership.
And anything outside
of that acronym,
I leave it to the rest of the team.
Zack, why are you doing
what you’re doing?
Why are you the CEO
of the JCC in Palo Alto? Why?
Because this is my calling.
This is what I’m meant to do.
Really, this is in my kishkes.
It’s what I am meant to be doing
at this time in my life.
I took this job. I loved AIPAC.
I ran the Pacific Northwest region
of AIPAC for almost 15 years.
I loved it. I didn’t want to leave.
But when somebody approached me
about this opportunity,
I realized that I --
I actually believe
the next 100 years
of American-Jewish life, Michael,
is going to be built
by the Jewish out here.
The last 100 years
of American-Jewish life
was built by East Coast Jews.
Everything that we know
from the synagogue structures,
the legacy institutions.
New York Jewish deli
defined our food, right?
Jewish humor came
from the Borscht Belt
in Broadway.
But the next 100 years
of American-Jewish life,
it's going to be built
by the Jewish out here
because they have the resources.
They are the ones
who are disenfranchised
with the way that we used to do
Jewish and they want
to change it up.
And they have the willingness
to break glass, move fast,
think like Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs.
So, those three things
mean that these Jews out here
are going to create
the next generation
of Jewish life.
They may not know it yet,
but I want to be a part of
that conversation.
I want to help them think
about what it means to do that.
That’s why I’m in this role.
I love it. I love it. Zack,
last question,
the most important one.
I need three words
that you would use
to define yourself
or any of your colleagues
at the JCC or AIPAC
would use to define Zack Bodner.
Good question.
I think passionate,
as you could probably hear from me.
I’m passionate about life,
about the causes
that I attach myself to,
about the people in my world.
So, number one is passionate.
I think number two is genuine.
I always have to be myself
even if that means
sharing bad news
as I’ve had to do this last week
with the changes that are coming
at the JCC because
of our budget situation.
Yeah.
And I think, finally,
the last word I would use
to describe myself is gregarious.
I’m a people person.
I like to be out there.
I like to engage. I like to --
which is why this lockdown
and the social distancing
is so hard for me
in particular, right?
This way of connecting is great,
but it doesn’t replace --
I want to give you a hug, Michael.
I want to just be able to sit
and break bread with you.
I want to share a drink with you.
And so, being the
gregarious extrovert that I am,
it’s very hard for me
in this situation.
But I think those are,
at least, some of the words
I would use to describe myself.
I love it. Zack,
thank you so, so much.
I love that you’re on
Jabotinsky suite right now.
[laughs]
- Thank you.
- Really phenomenal.
And thank you for the inspiration
and for the time.
I learned so much.
- So, thank you for that.
- Thank you, Michael.
Appreciate you inviting me.
Thank you and I’ll see you
at the JCC one day
- when corona is over.
- One day.
One day, God-willing.
- Take care.
- All right. Take care.
- Thanks, bye-bye.
- Bye-bye.